thank you very much for for this for
giving me this and i appreciate my
friends also my wife and my girlfriend i
mean my wife yeah sorry to say
i'm so i'm so sorry my wife lizzy i love
you so much aya i love you so much for
my heart so
must keep on supporting me and thanks
for to come to the game take a look at
birthdays and anniversaries in the
meantime happy 80th birthday to e norma
stitt uh quitman happy birthday to you
ms e norma hope you have a wonderful day
you know i was watching an episode of uh
you where measles came up
wait wait wait when did i mention
measles
i don't know it was on you
[Music]
what was on me what are you talking
about right what is this even hearing
what i'm saying i've never had the
measles what's on you
we never did
we never did a measles and vaccine
episode is this a joke i don't even know
what you're talking about it was on you
it was on youtube i've never had
raymond i've never had measles what are
you talking about this is stupid it was
an episode of a show laura
what's it called
you you it's called you i've never done
a show on measles i i just completely
give up we gotta get it it's a show i
give up called you on netflix
there's a show called lowering on
netflix
i'm moving on to adele i can't explain
this to you and if you're making
last-minute dinner plans you may have a
hard time getting in some of the titties
and some in some of the city's top spot
name something you might hurt yourself
right now oh lord
you know what i'm thinking uh you know
what i'm thinking a penis
shut up
nasty ass audience
it's things you can say to your dog but
not your girlfriend
[Applause]
come
[Applause]
this is you as an all-american
and a big opportunity for you in
hollywood you must have had to beat off
a lot of american men to get this part
why does that make you giggle did you
not have to beat them off
to get the role there was imagine there
was quite a few men up for the role as
well
they were they were
and compose yourself this is a question
for both mcgregor and uh cowboy i see
you both winning the championship coming
up soon could you see yourself fighting
each other coming up in the next year
yeah go ahead mcnugget you want to
answer that or no
ladies first
[Applause]
did a good job big shots and then on on
the other hand we got some stops our d
was good tonight
so we got to make sure our d stay good
before the game ken baismore told me
it's too far into the season to allow
two losses back to back if you agree
with that how important does that win oh
it's very important but it starts with
the d
so we got here we got to make sure we
keep playing defense
thank you joy a lot of base gazes we'll
let you go back to you guys
a 71 year old man is accused of an
inappropriately touching a
twelve-year-old girl at the walmart in
west mifflin sunday afternoon uh ninth
anniversary and hugh janus turning ten
we've mentioned
i'm sorry what
i'm sorry
it's one of those it's one of those
i totally fell for it
jacqueline jewett
julie jerkoff
forgive me kirkhoff
well the sign says that it's four
quarters for an hour but a quarter only
gets you 15 minutes so if my math is
correct that's not an hour that's not an
hour
but it is and also a quarter to two
minutes
rewind
take that off take that off you're right
15 minutes is it cool
i swear to god i do not do drugs i have
not had
liquor my friends are leaving me well
anyways we're doing a story about they
wanna change please don't put that on
pick up lines
in space have you ever been in a black
hole
[Applause]
not even light can escape
how about a swim in the milky way
and i mean i had like i had unlimited
like service after that i was getting
drinks and i was getting snacks and i
mean i was taking photos in the back
with all the all the students wait a
minute drinks you're 19 years old
i'm talking about mountain dews baby
all right
he called me baby he called me baby okay
um that's right ginger ale for sean
white outstanding
okay getting a little warm here
joining me now former arkansas governor
mike huckabee who's the host of [ __ ] of
huckabee right here on the fox news
channel he's also a former republican
president
crashed it was
no laughing matter and no it was not
part of their act the two elderly men
crashed their minivan on their way to
the local fair the driver 83 year old
james billingsley aka dimples the clown
collided
he missed the entrance but when he tried
to make a u-turn he slammed right into
an suv they're okay police say dimples
was wearing
oversized clown shoes
but police say
that they did not play a role in the
crash
for a lot of kids they cannot be out in
these sub-zero wind chills megan back to
you all right so if they're canceling
the train does that mean that you and i
are having another night in bed together
that's a long time oh my goodness
um
i have no words yeah except that we're
going to be on youtube in a few minutes